ganic de 12 años no huyo de ucrania
cuando empezaron las evacuaciones de
mujeres y niños se quedó en su casa por
lo que queda de ella para cuidar a su
madre ya su abuela su vivienda fue
destruida cuando las fuerzas rusas en un
intento fallido por apoderarse de la
capital ucraniana
bombardearon los suburbios de kiev
mi mamá necesita cirugía y por eso tengo
que ayudarle a usted porque estemos
allí
mi abuela van a ruinas de su casa
destruida y la ayuda para que su corazón
no esté tan pesado
y ya sé
antes de nyc pasaba las tardes montando
bicicleta jugando fútbol o con sus
perros y sus dos gatos blancos
ha perdido su infancia está haciendo un
trabajo que los niños no deberían tener
que hacer
no debería tener esas responsabilidades
simplemente debería estar disfrutando su
vida
desde que los misiles rusos impactaron
frente a la puerta de su casa en terni
hiv está encargado de cuidar el ganado
un sustento para la familia pero tiene
un sueño unirse a la lucha de su país
mi padre soldado mis hijos son soldados
mi abuelo fue soldado mi padre es re
soldado y yo también lo seré ese ha sido
mi sueño desde que estaba en la
guardería
cuando la guerra entra en su sexto mes y
con el temor de que los ataques se
intensifiquen el día de la independencia
de ucrania de la unión soviética
esta familia ucraniana guarda la
esperanza de algún día volver a su hogar
y regresar a la paz del campo sin los
ruidosos misiles que dañan todo a su
paso